-Jason, I'm so happy
that you're here, but,
we have to admit that you were
supposed to be
on "Stephen Colbert."
-You were not my first choice.
-Okay, I understand.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-But I was yours,
and then you hit him in the neck
with a blow dart of COVID.
-Yes.
-Right?
-Yes, yes.
-So Colbert got COVID and...
-And you're here.
-...Jimmy said,
"Hey, I got him."
[ Laughter ]
"Will you come over and play?"
-Stephen, get well soon.
We do love Stephen.
-No, it was going to be like me
and Laura Linney
and Julia Garner.
We were going to go do that.
It was going to be like
a cast interview.
Julia Garner couldn't
get here from London,
Stephen got COVID,
and Laura, whatever.
-I'm always here for you.
I'm always here for you,
whenever you're around.
-It worked out perfect.
-I, like, follow you around.
I go, I just want to make sure
you're okay, man.
You know I love my
Jason Bateman.
I need my Jason Bateman.
-I love it.
-The world, we need --
[ Cheering and applause ]
We'll do anything
for the Jason Bateman.
-But here's the thing.
We got no plan.
-No, we don't know what we're
going to talk about.
-We're just going
to free ball this, y'all.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Are you left-handed?
-I am. Well, here's a deal.
See? We're already improvising,
guys.
It's beautiful.
He's just doing visual cues.
I got my watch on this hand.
So, yeah,
so I write with the left,
I throw with the right.
I kick with the left,
I eat lefty, I play pool lefty,
I golf righty, bat righty.
I'm all messed up.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
That is really
interesting to me.
I did not know that.
-It's a problem.
-Yeah, but is it a talent?
Do your daughters
have this same talent?
Are they ambidextrous?
-I don't know if that's a
talent. I don't know
if left-handed
is being a talent.
They are talented.
-Yes.
But do they throw or they all --
-They don't.
And, in fact, speaking of golf,
I took the 10-year-old --
two daughters, 15 and 10 --
Maple, the 10-year-old,
I took her out
because Daddy likes
to play some golf,
and she's like,
"Well, what, why?
What are you doing out there?
That looks terrible."
And I said,
"Well, come out and try it."
So I took her out to play golf.
She plays righty as well.
And she was just striping it.
She's 10 years old
and I was like,
"Honey, here's the deal."
Because my wife hates golf.
My wife is like,
"What are you doing out there?
Think about all the housing,
if you got rid of all the golf
courses," it's like that.
[ Laughter ]
-That's so funny.
-So now I'm trying
to recruit Maple into the golf,
you know, addiction
because that means Daddy
can play a lot more golf.
We can travel.
I said, "Listen.
You get great at this,
you get all hopped up about it,
you and I can have
Daddy-daughter time.
We can travel."
I said, "There's courses
in France and stuff like that."
You know.
-Spend the rest of our lives
together.
-Yeah.
Mommy and Franny will have fun.
doing whatever the hell
they want to do."
-[ Laughs ] In the house.
-"And you and I, we can fly
around the world!"
-Yes!
-So she's working on her swing.
-Yeah, she is, yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's good.
You want that?
-I want it.
-They're very cute kids.
I was very lucky,
I got to do your podcast,
"Smartless."
-Mm-hmm.
-And it was very funny.
-We originally -- well, we had
booked Stephen Colbert,
but then, he couldn't.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, because he got COVID.
-You see what I did there?
-He got COVID again, yeah,
exactly.
I'm just making sure-
-Guy's lousy
with all kinds of viruses.
-The way the podcast works,
if you don't know "Smartless" --
-Hold for applause.
[ No applause ]
-We'll add it in later.
[ Laughter ]
You can't hear it, but it's
getting a standing ovation.
-It's pretty solid.
-Yeah, it's pretty serious.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Too late. Too late.
-It is the best.
No, it is so fun.
-Too late.
-But, basically,
it's you and two other hosts,
Sean Hayes and Will Arnett.
-Irrelevant.
-Irrelevant, yes.
It doesn't matter. It's really
"The Jason Bateman Show."
-Thank you.
-You're welcome.
One of you knows
who the guest is,
the other two do not.
-Yeah.
We take turns inviting guests
and we don't tell the other two
who that guest is,
so that the other two
do not need to prepare.
See, we don't need to do stuff
like this. You know?
-Yeah.
-Jimmy's been up for hours,
you know, since he nailed that
dart into Stephen's neck.
-Yeah, Colbert, yeah,
he's taking a day off.
I want to make sure I get
these questions in, yeah.
-Yeah, but we, you know,
we're -- actors are not
incredibly, should we say,
disciplined
with their work ethic.
So we like to have -- we don't
like to break a sweat.
So I said --
Or maybe Will said --
Will thinks it's his idea.
I think it was my idea.
That we don't tell the other
person who the guest is
so you don't have to do
any work.
You literally just lift up the
laptop, boom, we're recording,
and you can just be there just
an observer,
and, like, "Oh, my gosh, there's
Tom Hanks."
I've always wanted to ask
Tom Hanks this question.
And so it's very -- you know,
it's in real time,
like the listener would be.
You know? We're just --
-It's great.
-Yeah. It's really fun
because we get to talk to people
that are heroes of ours
and you can skip,
you know, four or five dates.
You can just get right
into asking
like you're trapped
in an elevator with somebody.
-Yeah, but is there any times
where you're doing the interview
and you go,
"Ooh, I kind of wish
I knew that person was coming
so I could prepare"?
Like Paul McCartney.
-Sean had Paul McCartney
was his guest...
[ Laughter and applause ]
...and, yeah, I was like --
Now, see, now the tepid applause
of Paul McCartney
makes me feel better about
no applause for "Smartless."
[ Laughter ]
-It wasn't tepid.
They weren't sure if they --
-The bar is down, yeah.
-They know that Paul McCartney's
not going to come out,
so they're just like,
"Yeah, yeah,
we love Paul McCartney,
but we know he's not there."
-If Paul McCartney
had a podcast, "Whoo!"
-No, no, no. They're like,
"Jason Bateman's here.
Let's get to the Bateman,"
that kind of standing O.
-But, no -- yeah, so --
Yeah, if I knew
Paul McCartney was coming out,
I would have been like,
you know --
because like, I love Wings --
-Me too.
-But the fact that he --
Did you know he was
in a band before that?
Like I had no idea.
So he comes out and I'm like --
I was a little embarrassed
because they start talking
about the Beatles.
-And you go, "I've never heard
of you."
-Well, there are no bugs
in my house.
What are you talking about?"
[ Laughter ]
And so that was
embarrassing for him.
I wish I'd had a little bit
of a heads-up, yeah.
-I want to talk about "Ozark."
It's the final season. It's
coming to an end. It's over.
-This is it. Well, listen,
"all good things..."
-Oh, it's great, yes.
It's a series final--
All good things,
all great things.
This is one of the best shows
I've ever seen.
-Thank you, buddy.
-And, dude, you are so good...
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Thank you.
-...in this. You are so good.
I just don't want it to end.
But I heard this --
that, originally,
you weren't supposed
to be in it.
You were just producing it
and directing.
-That was my original goal,
was to direct them all.
The acting part of it,
I can't remember
what the sequencing of it was,
but, yeah.
I -- I, um -- I just --
I don't know what it --
maybe because I've been doing
so much comedy,
the idea of doing something dark
and dramatic
and then, especially
as a director, too,
where, you know, you get
to shoot cinematic stuff
and like work with a composer
about creepy music
and all that stuff
was really exciting to me.
And the scripts were such
that it was like,
"Oh, yeah, you're going
to need to do that
to match these scripts
because they're dark."
-Yeah.
-And so that was the plan.
Couldn't make enough time
to direct them all,
so I just did the first two
and the last two
of that first season
and did a bunch since then.
-Yeah. I want to talk more
about "Ozark"
when we come back
and also show a clip.
More with Jason Bateman
after the break.
Come on back.